so this weekend is WrestleMania and it
got me thinking about a wrestler by the
name of Bret the Hitman Hart see you see
Bret Hart was a wrestler in a WWF now
WWE have for a very long time originally
as a tag team partner of Jim the anvil
Neidhart
known as the Hart Foundation and he had
a very nice career in the early to mid
80s through into the late 80s and then
into the early 90s men in the early 90s
he broke out of that as an individual
star and he is now widely considered
probably one of the best 10 to 15
wrestlers of all time why am I talking
about Bret the Hitman Hart in a video
that's probably predicated on thoughts
around business it's because of this
Bret Hart's nickname was the excellence
of execution and I begin with a lot of
thought lately to where the world's at
right now and the lack of people's
understanding of how much execution
matters I've realized that I'm not
investing in as many startups lately
because a lot of the people have very
nice ideas but I've watched so many so
many bright brilliant hungry ambitious
talented 22 to 26 year olds in the last
couple of years just completely failed
because they didn't have the guts and
more experience and more nuances to
navigate through the execution of what
it took to build a business or more
importantly the ability to adjust
halfway through as this world moves so
quickly that they're not able to change
their business model when the world
changes on them based on the promise of
how they launch their company see I get
a lot of emails from friends on Facebook
like oh my god they're so lucky it all
happened so fast
it didn't happen fast I've been [ __ ]
executing since I was 14 in a Malcolm
Gladwell world of 10,000 hours even
you're an expert I put in 50,000 hours
though he's like failed every classes
because I was running businesses since I
was 14 years old
everyone's got Wine Library TV such a
phenomenon I have ran Wine Library a
wine retail and
business from 1998 until early 2006
every single day for 17 hours a day
before I started Wine Library TV to get
internet famous see execution matters
and putting in the work matters Bret
Hart grew up in a wrestling family he
was eight and nine when he was in the
squared circle every day getting thrown
around like a rag doll by his older
brothers and his dad put in the work
execute and then you've got a shot your
ideas are cute and all but without
execution most of you will fail it is
time in 2013 that we start getting
dramatically more practical and start
looking at people that are 28 29 42 49
54 57 and understand yeah maybe they
don't know what snapchat is but their
execution value is high